a little bit more okay hang on
oh I did it I did it I am I'm hanging
let's go let's go oh my God no no no no
no I fell off can you go to like an
external view oh I I see you all right
oh you're dangling dude
so I wonder if you can like fully load
one of these up
all right top test let's go
all right welcome to top test this is
Aaron Sampson with David Amani we're
taking a look at Modern Warfare 2. some
of the stuff we're gonna test today are
things developers told us we're in the
game or we're just gonna test the limit
of equipment and have some fun so let's
get into it what can stop a riot shield
or should I say what can stop a riot
shield with it being broken against VTOL
and Chopper gun right now Riot Shield vs
lmg with um anti-armor rounds
I'm getting nothing right Shield vs prox
mine
and here we go
totally eats it no problem yeah Riot
Shield vs proximity mind standing
[Laughter]
so you kind of like walk like head first
into it I guess yeah so what's
interesting is I kept walking and it
actually jumped over the top of my
shield right Shield versus Claymore
jeez dude just no problem at all
whoa right shield first claim we're
standing up no problem I don't know why
that should have actually killed my
ankles let's try it do you have another
one by chance
dude it is no problem right Shield
versus Claymore even standing up no
problem rocket launcher versus riot
shield three two one boom
man uh try and hit me like towards my
feet a little bit I'm gonna Crouch that
dang just no problem at all rat Shield
versus drill charge
it like stuck to your foot like it
bounced off your shield and then it
attaches but yeah
that's awesome we already know that the
riot shield is potentially broken
against VTOL and Chopper Gunner right
now but let's see if it'll save you from
uh like a guided missile strike
foreign
okay so it will not save you from a
cruise missile ride Shield versus
Juggernaut
no way
so yeah nope it stops Juggernaut too I
will say I was getting some pretty
insane experience gains so I think if
you see a juggernaut you should 100 get
them to shoot at you if you're a shield
person
that is crazy
ow I wonder how long it actually
I would probably take forever to kill
you with this stuff
like
you're a cow ow what do you have like 10
hits now 11. oh I can see some I think I
can see some cracks in my
oh my God how many
how many rideshield bashes does it take
to take down the juggernaut
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
Shield it is going to take you
approximately one entire round to do so
so okay so you were always able to in
Modern Warfare 2019 if you go prone fast
enough you could actually get underneath
a proximity mine but the question is now
you can dolphin dive can you just see
one in dolphin diver right away so let's
give this a try see if you can just
dolphin dive a prox mine and survive
limited dolphin dive on the mine
just right on that battle oh boy all
right I'm ready
man
so not only can you just go pro now but
like I wonder what happens if you if you
spotted like a little bit late
did you make it yeah
then you're good to go confirmed you can
you can dolphin dive and survive a uh
proximity mine for newer players to the
game when you're across lethals there's
an old way of handling it which we'll
show you in a second but also there's
now shock sticks and we're going to test
if shock sticks are just as good as the
old way so let's go with shock 6 versus
the various lethals are supposed to save
you from like you know you see a
claymore peeking around the corner shock
sticks versus proximity mines uh let's
start with holding
oh it's such a good that's such a good
detail
oh my God so you have to be careful
because if the person
is uh has a weapon they won't they will
shoot you as they are exploding
so shock stick versus proximity mine
yeah wow that totally works that and
that will save you a shock stick versus
Claymore holding
uh you know that kind of makes sense
though because the claymore's like
aiming out that is a fantastic uh piece
of detail because like the proximity
mine will blow all the way out but a
claymore blows in a single Direction
that's why you died with the proximity
mind but not the Claymore okay so the
the proper way that we were trying to
show you before we showed you the
awesome way is just shock stick versus
Claymore if you see the the laser beams
around the corner
all right so that totally works and then
you can get right on by
shock stick versus bomb drone
oh
oh wow there was two stages to it that
was fascinating so it disabled it and
then it destroyed it okay so now let's
go back to the old method which in some
cases is actually better than
um shock stick and and there's some
cases here that we'll show you in a
second so let's do the stun grenade
versus all the things that we just
tested Sun grenade versus Claymore
so check it out it totally disables it
for a second or two oh well interesting
yeah we'll let you write on by it let's
try that with the proximity mind I'm
really curious if it'll work for that as
well
so I got the hit
and it definitely lit off so it does not
work against proximity Minds okay so if
you see a proximity mine you better have
a shock stick but if you have a stun
grenade you can definitely use it
against the Claymore all right it's time
to play a little game called can you
hack it or DDOS it let's start with DDOS
and just see what happens
proximity mine disabled
so
let's see how long
so in the game of kidney hack it or DDOS
it yes you can DDOS proximity minds but
it's just very very temporary hacking it
with a spotter perk is way Superior to
DDOS when it comes to these things so
hack it or DDOS it with C4 let's start
with DDOS
nope nothing
and then try now
so DDOS just temporarily stops it but if
you hack it with spotter let's go ahead
and toss C4 again
one second okay
oh unlike the mines it just it just
destroys it which is really interesting
okay so what you would have to do to
actually save yourself from something
like C4
is quite a lot you'd have to first DDOS
it so go ahead and throw it
to save yourself from getting hit and
then you would have to hack it
immediately
and Honestly by that point the other
player probably would have killed you so
I don't think it's that useful how many
times can you and somebody else hack of
mine
two three
four
you should just be infinite
[Music]
well it seems I don't know unless
something happens here real soon it
seems like you can hack Minds back and
forth infinitely
shock stick
the other thing that's a little bit
confusing in this game is you know when
you have an lmg
um what you can and can't shoot through
is not 100 clear so we want to test a
couple of surfaces just so you get a
good idea of what it is you can shoot
through so we'll start with a cinder
block wall here I'm also using ammo on
this gun that increases penetration a
bit yup
it absolutely is
definitely going through
so it goes through like regular stone
walls and buildings how about like two
stone walls can you penetrate two walls
for a Kill
so the bullets we're going through they
weren't hitting me
um but I was getting like suppressed and
then we're gonna try wall penetration
test here for walls that are like a like
a chimney and then maybe something on
the inside like a washing machine
we'll see if it goes through
like going through it all
um
no well like one bullet went through and
it like suppressed me but everything
else like there wasn't a single one
let me try it with anti-armor rounds
yep
totally goes through
that is cool
so anti-armor rounds really do actually
like increase wall penetration for
things like lmgs so regular lmg rounds
will go through like cinder block and
cars but they won't go through thicker
walls then if you add a lmg round that
has penetration it'll go through one or
two of these walls and it'll go through
cars but it won't go through things with
like stuff on the other side and then if
you use anti-armor rounds it'll go
through stuff that has stuff on the
other side so there's a huge range
that's that's really interesting so
we'll go ahead and say you know
definitely confirm that there's a wide
range of wall penetration in this game I
know that there's a lot more that we can
do with this game Modern Warfare 2 has a
pretty fun sandbox so let us know what
you want to see us try next all right
have a good one everybody thanks for
watching I wish it could be different
but
I thought we were friends uh is it time
for me to get RPGs
maybe over in the middle again
oh I'm in the middle
[Music]
yeah we need a picture
oh I am in the middle all right
okay I'm done that was it that was the
last one I promise